the heat wave is affecting everybody you
know yeah it is so hot people are even
accepting cold drinks from Bill Cosby
how are we doing we good we good I could
see the crowd the crowd was like hey I
don't know and they're like you know
they have air-conditioning in here right
I'm actually this causes a breeze yeah
it's actually because of the heat wave a
lot of people across the country are
without power yeah they're called
Democrats
[Laughter]
it's not funny cuz it's true now this is
really weird we tape a little early just
a couple hours early I don't know what's
gonna happen but the Supreme Court if
you all heard what's gonna happen
tonight
tonight President Trump is going to
announce his pick for the Supreme Court
in between segments of American Ninja
Warrior that's true that is true Trump
plans to pick whichever judge can make
it first over the 30-foot rope wall
before it's hard to do it a black rope
oh yeah I think I said that to the
audience and they thought that's the
joke no that's the part that's real it's
impossible to do a joke about that I
know he's making a live announcement
tonight during American Ninja Warrior
about who his supreme court pick is
right yeah I'm sure there's a set of
steak knives and yes all now and his
steak at a bookstore in Virginia a woman
spotted former White House adviser Steve
Bannon and called him a piece of trash
yeah Bannon is demanding an apology and
so is trash
speaking of trumps people over the
weekend Trump's one of the top Trump
advisor Stephen Miller was heckled by a
restaurant employee so Miller angrily
threw away $80 worth of sushi yeah when
they heard this Kentucky coal miner said
he really is one of us $80 worth his
sushi down the drain you won't see that
joke on air now I think you will
actually you saved it thank you very
much in Utah a teacher was caught
selling meth from her car yeah yeah you
could tell she's a teacher because she
made sure to bring enough for everyone
and that's
[Applause]
you